We've distinguished three different views as to the secret are key to personal
identity across time.
There's the soul view,
the body view and the personality view.
Putting aside for the most part,
this whole view because I've argued it to our no souls,
although occasionally I'd bring it out just for the sake of comparison and
contrast.
Main question we want to ask ourselves is how to choose between the body view
and the personality view.
The body view says follow the body.
If somebody around in the future has got my body,
that's me.
The personality view says follow the personality.
That is the set of beliefs,
desires,
memories,
goals,
ambitions and so forth.
Somebody around in the future that's got my memories,
my beliefs,
my desires.
That's me.
How should we choose between these two views?
As I mentioned the end of last lecture but I want to do is offer us a set of
thought experiments that they've gotta be thought experience because in in real
life bodies and personalities go hand in hand,
but by doing some science fiction experiments we can take them apart and ask
ourselves,
well,
which one do I think is me?
When my body goes one way and my personality goes another way?
Where do I go?
And as I again,
just to remind you,
in order to get the intuition is actually flowing.
What I'm going to do once I've separated the Ma,
the body and the personality in this way is torture one of the end products and
so I'm going to be asking you to sort of put yourself in the first person.
Imagine this is happening to you and ask yourself which one do I want to be
tortured or which one do I want to not be tortured?
Because that will give you some kind of evidence as to which one you take to be
you.
And think about this and that kind of special first person,
ego concerned way that comes naturally to us.
Just bracket any moral concerns you may have about,
about torturing.
Other people are agreeing that somebody else should be tortured for,
for our,
for our purposes.
As you know right now,
you know,
if I brought up a volunteer from the class and I'm asking you,
here's you,
there's the other volunteer,
which one do you want to be tortured?
We let that one be tortured.
Don't let it happen to me.
That's how we know,
you know,
this is me speaking.
All right,
so that's the question I'm going to ask you.
I'll,
I'll probably slip into talking about this experiment as though it's being done
to me,
but to get it vivid,
you should think of it,
uh,
as,
as though it's being done to you.
And I'll mention just in passing that,
uh,
these,
these thought experiments that are about to give it,
I'm going to get a pair of them are coming from Bernard Williams.
He was a a British philosopher.
All right,
so case number one here.
Here you are,
the mad scientist has has kidnapped you.
And he says,
I've been working on mine transfer machines.
And what I'm going to do is,
you know,
I've got you and I've also kidnapped somebody else over here.
Yep,
Linda.
Okay.
And I'm going to hook you up to my machines and,
and swap your minds.
And what that means is I'm going,
I sort of read off the memories and the beliefs and the desires from your,
from your brain and read off the memories and desires and beliefs from Linda's
brain.
And then I'm going to electronically transfer Linda's memories and beliefs and
so forth over here and in plant the Monta,
this brain and take your memories and beliefs and so forth and implant them
Monta Linda's brain.
And so,
you know,
first we'll put you to sleep and what we do,
all of this procedure.
And then when you wake up,
you will wake up in Linda's body.
There'll be,
there'll be something here that,
that,
you know,
you'll,
you'll wake up and you'll say,
you know,
what am I doing?
This new body?
What,
what happened to my beard?
Uh,
you know,
uh,
how come,
how come I'm speaking in this high female
boy?
Whatever it is.
But you'll,
yeah,
you'll think to yourself,
well,
you know,
here I am Shelly Kagan.
I seem to be inhabiting a Linda's body.
Don't know how that happened.
Oh yes,
the mad scientist kidnapped me and he transferred are transferred to us.
You know,
he swapped us,
he swapped our bodies,
swapped our minds.
I guess the whole thing works.
So the mad scientist explains all of this to you,
but in order to sort of give it a little kicker,
because he's also an evil,
mad side that may be evil already,
but cause he's an evil,
mad scientist,
he says,
and then when I'm done,
so over here we've got Shelley's body,
but you know,
Linda's personality,
uh,
you know,
so Linda thinking,
what am I doing and what am I doing in Charlotte,
his body?
How did I go to Butte?
Right?
Um,
so over here,
Linda in Shelley's body over here,
Shelley and Linda's body.
I'm going to torture one of these,
but because I'm a generous,
evil,
mad scientist,
I want to ask you which one should I torture?
Now,
when I think about this,
and again,
I'm inviting you to think about this in the first person,
is all this is happening to you.
When I think about this,
I say torture the one over here.
No,
I'm going to be over here in Linda's body.
Horrified at what's been going on,
horrified that she's being tortured,
but at least it's not happening to me.
That's the intuition I've got.
When I think about this case,
when the mad scientist asks me,
which one are these two,
should I torture?
I say torture this one
because if I were to say torture this one and then he does it,
think about what's going to happen.
I'll be thinking,
I'm Shelly Kagan.
All this is what a horrible thing.
Where did I stop the bay naked?
I don't want that to happen to me.
If this one's being tortured,
nobody thinking to himself,
Oh,
I'm Shelly Kagan in horrible pain,
so I want this one to be tortured.
All right.
That's the intuition I've got about the case.
Now,
if you've got that same intuition,
think about the implications of that intuition.
You're saying that I,
Shelly Kagan ended up over here,
but that's not my body.
This is Linda's body.
Shelly Kagan's old body is over here,
but this is the one that's me because this is the one that I don't want to have
tortured,
so the body isn't the key to personal identity.
Personality is the key to personal identity.
This has got my personality,
my memories of growing up in Chicago,
becoming a philosopher.
Now you know my thoughts about what I want to have happen to my children,
my fears about how I'm going to explain what's going on to my wife,
whatever it is.
This is the Shelly Kagan personality over here.
This is me that follows them that this intuition suggests that what I find
intuitively plausible is the personality theory of personal identity.
That's total different story.
Both of these stories as they say,
come from Bernie Williams.
Yeah.
Bernoy and says,
Hey,
here's another example we can think about.
Mad scientist again,
kidnaps,
you know,
you kidnaps Linda
and he says,
Shelley,
I got some news for you.
I tell you,
say I'm switching between you and Shell and me,
you know,
says Shelley,
I've got some news for you.
I'm going to torture you and said,
no,
please don't do it to me.
Please,
please don't torture me.
He says,
well,
you know,
I'm in the mad scientist businesses is what I do.
I'm going to torture you,
but because I'm a generous,
mad scientist,
before I torture you,
what I'm going to do is give you amnesia.
I'm going to completely scrubbed,
clean your brain so that you won't remember that your Shelly Kagan,
you won't have any memories of growing up in Chicago.
You won't have any memories of deciding to become a philosopher.
You won't remember getting married or having children and you won't remember the
all.
You won't have any desire.
The whole thing.
Wipe clean,
complete,
perfect Amnesia before I taught you.
You don't,
you feel better.
No,
I don't feel better.
I'm still going to be tortured.
And now we've added sort of insult to injury.
I've got Amnesia as well as being tortured.
No comfort there.
Well he says,
look,
I'll make the deal sweeter for you after I give you Amnesia before I torture
you,
I will drive you insane and make you believe that your Linda,
I've been studying Linda,
you know,
there she is.
I've been reading her psychology by looking at her brain waves and so forth and
so on.
And so I'm going to delude you into thinking that you're Linda.
I'm going to make you think,
oh,
I'll go.
You want to talk about it?
Oh,
I'm Linda.
And,
and,
and you'll have the memories of Linda of growing up in Pennsylvania and you'll
remember Linda's family and like,
Linda,
you'll want to be an author or whatever it is the lender wants to be.
And then I'll talk to you.
Are you happy now?
No,
I'm not happy now.
First of all,
I'm being tortured.
I was given Amnesia.
Now you've driven me crazy and make me diluted me into thinking that I'm Linda.
No comfort there.
He says,
okay,
last attempt to mate,
you're not being very reasonable.
He says,
last attempt I'm going to after I drive you crazy,
make you think you're Linda.
I'm going to do the corresponding thing for Linda.
I'm going to give her Amnesia and then I'm going to drive her crazy and make her
think that she,
Shelly,
give her all of your memories and beliefs and desires.
Now is it okay that I'm going to torture you know it.
It hardly makes it,
you know it was bad enough.
I was being tortured and given Amnesia and driven insane.
It doesn't really make it any better that you're also going to give Amnesia and
drive insane.
Somebody else.
Don't torture me
if you've got to torture somebody.
I say in my non ethical mood,
if you've got a torture,
somebody do it to her,
don't do it.
To me,
when I think about this second case,
that's my intuition.
Nothing about the implications of this second case for the theory of personal
identity.
If I don't want me,
if I don't want this thing over here to be tortured,
that must be,
because I think it's me,
but if it's me,
what's the key to personal identity?
Well,
not personality because after all,
this doesn't end up with Shelly Kagan's personality before the torture.
Shelly Kagan's personalities over there.
Okay,
this is Shelly Kagan's body and that suggest if I don't want to be,
I don't want this to be tortured.
It's because I believe in the body theory of personal identity.
Follow the body,
not follow the personality.
Even though he swapped our personalities,
it's still me.
He's torturing.
That's the intuition I've got.
When I think about Bernard Williams,
his second case.
Okay.
Now we're in a bit of a pickle here from the philosophical point of view because
when we thought about the first case,
the intuition seem to be
personalities.
The key to personal identity.
Yeah,
but when we thought about the second case,
the intuition,
it seems to be,
Huh?
Body is the key to personal identity.
That's bad.
Right?
Two different cases give us two different diametrically opposed answers on the
very same question.
One sec
and it's worth still,
oh,
of course.
You know,
if you don't share the intuitions that I just,
you know,
I was being honest with you.
Those really are my intuitions.
When I think about these cases,
if you're with me,
you're in a philosophical problem.
If you're not with me,
if you,
if you didn't have the same intuitions that maybe you don't have a problem,
but,
but I've got a problem and it's worse still because it's not really,
if we're careful and think about it,
it's not really as though we have two different cases and intuitively we want to
give different answers to those two different cases.
Really all we've got there is just one case.
It's the very same case,
that very same story that I told two different times in both cases before the
torturing ends to go,
goes in,
there's Shelly Kagan's body over here with Linda's personality and there's
Linda's body over here with Shelly Kagan's personality and we're asking which
one do you want to be tortured?
It's the very same setup.
I just emphasize different elements in a way to sort of manipulate your
intuitions,
but it's the very same case.
It can't be that in one of them follow the body and the other one followup
personality,
so it's very hard to know what moral should we draw the the appeal to intuition,
thinking about these cases doesn't seem to take us very far.
There was a question back there.
Yeah.
Nice suggestion for the suggestion was this.
When the mad scientist put my personality I Shelly Kagan personality on until
Linda,
his body,
he had to modify Linda's brain and in modifying Linda's brain,
this was the question that was just raised,
hasn't he actually made that brain more like Shelly Kagan's brain then Linda's
brain and if that's right,
shouldn't we say member?
The best form of the body view I argued previously was the brain version.
So if this is really Shelly Kagan's brain over here,
then this isn't a problem for the body view.
We were deceived when we said the body view said,
this is Shelly Kagan.
Really the body view to it.
The best version of the body of you that is the brain version now has to say,
oh we Shelley's brain and put it here.
Well if you're prepared to say that,
then indeed you will be able to say,
yeah,
that's the,
it's the,
it's the body view.
The body of view says don't do it to this one rather don't do to this one.
Cause this is Shelly Kagan.
I don't actually find myself though inclined to agree with you that this has
become Shelly Kagan's brain.
If you ask me,
where's Shelly Kagan's legs,
there's still here.
Where's Shelly Kagan's heart?
There's still here.
Where's Shelly Kagan's brain?
It's still here,
right?
It's not as though what the scientists did was open up my skull.
Take the brain out.
At least if you,
that's the way you were imagining that.
Don't imagine that this is all electronic transfer.
Is that as how he took the brain out and literally moved that hunk of tissue
over here.
All he's done is reprogram Linda's brain analogy here.
My Cup might be helpful.
Think of the difference between the computer and the programs and files saved on
the computer personalities.
A little bit like a program that's running on the computer though we have to
have not just the generic program but this specific data files and databases and
so forth.
What the mad scientist did in effect was wipe out the hard drive put in the
other programs from the Shelly Kagan computer,
but it's still in the very same computer.
It's the still,
it's still the same central processing unit or so.
It seems to me.
Of course it's true that now in a certain way Linda's brain will be similar to
the way that Shelly Kagan's brain had been before in terms of how the,
you know,
as it were,
the floppy drives are set up but still wears literally speaking.
Shelly Kagan's brain.
I want to say it's over there.
Not over here.
There was another question.
Comment.
Yeah.
This counting of the body,
brain,
heart,
everything is over here.
Then
I would want the body,
I meant to get the story is that until we see,
because your personality is not going to feel the pain.
I'm not quite sure what the question is.
So the thought is,
look over here.
We've got Shelly Kagan's body with Linda's personality.
If we torture in this one,
this thing,
whoever it is,
is going to think to itself.
I'm Linda,
I'm in horrible pain.
I wish it stopped.
I wonder whether I'll ever see Linda's husband again.
All right.
Over here we've got Linda's body,
Shelly Kagan's personality.
If we torture this one,
of course.
Yeah,
to torture.
Yet you cause pain,
the bodies,
but the pain gets felt in,
you know,
in the mind.
So over here we've got something that's going to think to itself.
I'm Shelly Kagan,
I'm in horrible pain.
I wonder whether I'll ever see Shelly Kagan's wife again.
Yes,
of course.
We're torturing bodies by torturing the bodies.
We caused pain to the mines.
The personalities who have beliefs about who's hurting.
What I'm inviting you to think about is which one?
If you had to choose between these two gruesome scenarios,
which one would you rather save?
Which one would you rather protect?
Which do you care more about?
Making sure that your lump of flesh doesn't have its neurons hurt or making sure
that the person who's thinking to yourself,
I'm Shelly Kagan or you know,
whatever your name is.
All right.
Yeah I'm in pain.
You don't want to be thinking I Shelly Kagan,
I'm in pain.
Or if your name is,
you know Mary,
I'm Mary,
I'm in pain.
That's what we're trying to get straight on here.
No,
the trouble though is that you're telling the very same story two different
times and I find myself sometimes being pulled this way.
Sometimes he's being pulled that way.
So I can't use thinking about the Williams cases as a method of deciding what do
I really believe the body view or the personality view I find myself is spin the
story one way and I follow the body.
You spin the story and other way and I follow the personality.
If we're gonna have a way to decide between these two theories,
it seems as though we need some other kinds of arguments.
At least I need some of the kinds of arguments cause cause of the intuitions
I've got about the cases.
So let me turn to a different approach to solving the question.
Answering the question.
Which one should we believe?
It starts by raising a certain philosophical objection to the personality
theory.
It's going to say,
look,
the personality theory,
your personal identity has an implication that we cannot possibly accept.
So we have to reject the view and then become body theorist.
If there are no souls,
here's,
here's the objection.
A common enough objection.
It's probably occurred to some of you coordinate the personality theory.
Whether somebody is me,
depends on whether he's got,
yeah,
my beliefs.
You know,
for example,
the belief that I'm Shelly Kagan,
professor of philosophy at Yale University.
Okay,
well I'm sort of not a special interesting fellow sauce.
Let's make it more dramatic and think about Napoleon.
You've probably read about this thing again.
Every now and then there are sort of crazy people who think they're Napoleon.
So imagine that there's right now somebody in an insane asylum in Michigan.
You know who,
who's got the thought?
I am Napoleon.
Well,
the objection says clearly this guy is just insane,
right?
He is not Napoleon.
He's David Smith who grew up in Detroit or whatever.
He just insanely believes he's Napoleon.
Yet the personality theory,
the objection says would tell us that he is Napoleon.
It's because he's got the beliefs of Napoleon.
He's gotten Napoleon's personality.
Since that's obviously the wrong thing to say about the case,
we should reject the personality view
for Knoxville quick.
The personality view doesn't say anybody who has any elements at all of my
personality is me.
One Belief in Commons,
obviously not enough.
We all believe the earth is round.
That's not enough to make somebody else in me.
Of course,
the belief I am Napoleon is a much rarer belief.
I presume that none of you have that belief.
I certainly don't have that belief.
Napoleon had it and and David Smith in Michigan's got it,
but so what one belief,
even one very unusual beliefs,
not enough to make somebody Napoleon according to the personality theory,
to be Napoleon,
you've got to have the very same overall personality,
which is a very big,
complicated set of beliefs and desires and ambitions and memories.
David Smith doesn't have that.
David Smith in the insane asylum and Michigan does not remember conquering
Europe.
He doesn't remember being crowned emperor.
He doesn't remember being defeated by the British.
He doesn't have any of those memories,
probably doesn't even speak French.
Napoleon spoke French.
He doesn't have Napoleon's personality,
so the David Smith case isn't really bothersome.
It's not really a counter example to the personality theory.
Personality theory says to be Napoleon,
you've got to have Napoleon's personality,
but David Smith doesn't.
So of course we can all agree.
David Smith,
despite thinking he's Napoleon is not Napoleon.
No problem here for the personality theory,
but we could tweak the case.
We could revise the case.
Some photo of the personality theory could say,
okay,
imagine that this guy in Michigan does have Napoleon's personality.
He's got the memories of being crowned emperor and being defeated,
conquering Europe.
He's got all of those memories and remember,
we want him to have Napoleon's personality.
He doesn't have any David Smith memories.
It doesn't have any memories of growing up in Detroit.
How could Napoleon have memories of growing up in Detroit?
The polling grew up in France.
Okay.
The objection then says,
even if,
yeah,
this guy had all of Napoleon's memories,
beliefs,
desires,
personality still wouldn't be Napoleon.
So the personality theory has got to go,
well,
when I think about this example,
I think now we've got it right?
That is,
that is what the personality theory has to say about that case.
But I'm not so confident anymore that it's the wrong thing to say.
So think of this as it were from the point of view of Napoleon,
right?
So there was Napoleon in the 18 hundreds conquering Europe,
uh,
and uh,
and being crowned emperor being defeated by the British being,
being sent to exile on Elba.
Right?
And I forget where Napoleon actually dies,
but you know,
he's got memories of,
of getting sick and ill and,
and,
and the light begins to fade and he sort of,
you know,
well goes unconscious
and then,
well,
let's,
let's at least try to describe it this way.
He wakes up and he wakes up in Michigan.
He thinks to himself,
I low just three Napoleon,
fuck am I doing in Michigan?
I don't,
I don't speak French,
so I'm going to drop that.
Right.
But yeah,
the last thing I remember,
I was,
I was going to bed for my fatal illness.
I know I'm the aisle of Elba.
What?
How did I get over here?
I wonder if there's any chance of reassembling my army and reconquering the
world
if he had all of that.
It's not so clear to me that it would be the wrong thing to say that by Dali.
This is Napoleon.
I mean,
it would be totally bizarre.
Things like this don't happen,
but of course we're doing science fiction stories here.
So we'd say to ourselves,
wouldn't somehow Napoleon has been reborn or reincarnated taking over by some
sort of process of possession the body of the former David Smith,
but now it's Napoleon.
I find myself thinking,
you know,
maybe that would be the right thing to say.
Yeah.
Okay.
All right.
So the,
the,
the thought was,
look,
this guy over here,
David Smith's body with Napoleon's personality,
and let's,
let's be clear about this.
There is no underlying David Smith personality still there to have the counter
example or the example that we're after.
It's,
it can't be that he's got mixed together memories of growing up in France and
memories of growing up in Detroit.
He never thinks to himself,
I'm David Smith.
How did I become Napoleon?
You got that junk.
You don't have Napoleon's personality.
He's just gotten a Polina personality through and through.
Well,
the,
the question then was maybe that's not,
so after all,
he doesn't really have Napoleon's experiences.
Did he?
Napoleon had the experience of being crowned emperor,
but this guy didn't have the experience of being crowned emperor.
Maybe what we should say is he thinks he remembers the experience of being
crowned emperor,
but it's a fake memory.
It's a illusion or a delusion,
but he didn't really have the genuine memory to have the genuine memory.
He has to have been crowned emperor and he wasn't crowned emperor.
Napoleon was crowned emperor.
Well that's what we could say,
but we can't say that until we decide.
He's not Napoleon after all,
if the personality theories right,
since he does have all of these memories or semi memories or quasi memories or
whatever we should call them,
if that's the key,
then it needs Napoleon.
So He is remembering being crowned emperor.
If you want to say no,
no,
no.
Those memories are illusions.
It must be because you don't think he really Napoleon,
in which case what you're discovering is you don't really believe the
personality theory.
Why isn't he Napoleon?
It's not his body.
You know the body of the Napoleon is not this body and to being a,
and you got to have Napoleon's body looked possible position,
right?
That's the,
that's the thought that the body theorists are trying to elicit in you when they
offer these Napoleon ESC counter examples.
You could match the personality as much as you want,
but it's still not Napoleon.
Don't you agree?
That's what they say and if you do agree that shows,
you don't really accept the personality theory.
I'm not going to try to settle this here.
You know who should we believe that personality theory or the body theory,
I'm trying to invite you to think about the implications and the differences
between these views.
So is to get clear in your own mind about which of these you accept
in many moods.
At least when I think about not the simple,
the ordinary David Smith case with a single belief or two,
but the full bodied has a bad term,
the full blown Napoleon case with all the memories,
all the boys,
you know,
suppose David Smith there things I remember,
I remember,
I can't say it in French accent.
I remember plain,
you know as a lad in France buried my little toy Sabre,
you know,
some memory that Napoleon never wrote down in his diaries.
And we go and we,
when we dig up in in France and there is the saber,
right?
This guy remembers things that Napoleon would remember,
find myself thinking.
Maybe that's Napoleon.
Imagine a slightly different version of this case.
Napoleon dies
on his death bed,
wakes up in heaven saying
juice.
We end up holding on.
I was the emperor Europe up and now I have come to my dude reward.
I am here and have him.
Well,
seems like what we'd want to says.
Yeah,
that's Napoleon
the,
and even if it doesn't have Napoleon's body,
Napoleon's corpse is rotted in France.
God gives Napoleon some new angelic body.
Seems straight forward.
If it's got the polio,
Ian's memories,
beliefs,
desires,
goals and so forth and so on.
When we say it's Napoleon,
imagine,
imagine that back to this earth,
this Napoleon type of case happened all the time.
We might have a term for this sort of thing.
Possession.
All right.
Every now and then people get,
people's bodies get possessed.
They become this other person who's now personality has taken over.
This happened frequently enough instead of just a little science fiction story,
like with the David Smith case,
maybe we'd say,
yeah,
possessions,
one of these things that need to be explained.
I know.
How is it the personality travels will maybe there'll be some sort of physical
explanation for it
still.
Maybe we'd say yet the people had been taken over,
they become somebody else.
So speaking,
personally,
I don't find the Napoleon objection.
A telling one doesn't give me reason to reject the personality theory,
but we can now tweak the worry in a slightly different way.
Okay,
so here was Napoleon back in France with his memories and his beliefs and so
forth and so on.
That's bed goes to sleep,
goes unconscious,
whatever it is.
I told you a story in which he wakes up or his personality wakes up,
whoever we should put it in Michigan.
But if it could happen in Michigan,
I suppose it could also happen in New York.
And if it could happen in New York and it could happen in Michigan,
I suppose it could happen in New York and Michigan.
Okay.
So right now let's imagine two people with Napoleon's personalities,
complete personalities.
One of them in Michigan,
one of them in New York.
Whoa.
What should we say now?
What is the personality theory going to say about this case?
So I don't know how to draw a personalities very well on the board.
So I'll draw a little stick figures of bodies.
But I mean these to be the personality.
So here we've got,
you know,
the,
the continuing evolving over time.
This is all taking place in France,
the personality of Napoleon in France.
You know,
there's the deathbed scene
now up here we had somebody with Napoleon's personality continuing.
Of course he's going to change.
It's got to evolve.
Just like the actual historical Napoleon kept having new beliefs and new
desires.
If it's really wasn't Napoleon in Michigan Hilton,
he'll start having some new desires and beliefs.
You know about Michigan,
which perhaps Napoleon never gave any thought to it all.
Who knows?
So this is Michigan over here.
And I said I was willing to entertain the possibility
that this is all Napoleon
Napoleon.
If you think of it,
the polling is a person extended through space and time according to personality
view.
What makes somebody in the future,
the same person as somebody in the past is if it's part of the same ongoing
personality.
So maybe that's what we got going on in the Michigan case.
Now we imagine now a new version of the worry,
somebody with Napoleon's personality over here in New York.
Now,
if the Michigan guy hadn't been there,
but I wouldn't have done,
if I believe in the personality theory or when I believe in the personality
theory and say,
look,
Napoleon reincarnated in New York,
that's what the personality theory should say,
and I said,
it doesn't seem like a crazy thing to say if we only had the guy in New York.
Just like it wasn't a crazy thing to say if we only had the guy in Michigan.
The trouble is,
imagine the case
where we've got one guy who's got off Napoleon's personality in Michigan,
one guy,
he's got all of Napoleon's personality in New York.
Now what should we say?
What are the choices here?
Well,
I suppose one possibility would be to say the guy in New York is Napoleon.
The guy in Michigan isn't,
he's just an insane guy who's gotten Napoleon's personality.
You could say that the reason that it seems difficult to say though is because
it seems like it would be just as plausible to say the reverse,
say no,
no,
no.
It's not the New York fellow who's Napoleon.
It's the Michigan Fellow who's Napoleon.
Well,
we couldn't say that,
but the difficulty is there seems to be no good reason to favor the Michigan
fellow over the New York fellow.
Just like there was no good reason to favor the New York fellow over the
Michigan fellow saying that one of them's Napoleon and the other one isn't.
Seems very hard to believe.
Well then what's the alternative?
Well,
I suppose another possibility is to say,
well,
he said other possibility worth mentioning.
Okay.
Is to say they're both Napoleon
somehow bizarrely enough,
Napoleon split in to two,
but
when splitting into two,
he split into tryign to two bodies,
but they are both Napoleon.
Very important to understand how bizarre this proposal would be.
The claim is not.
Now we've got to Napoleon's who of course not identical to each other.
No,
no.
We've got a single Napoleon,
I'm Napoleon who was in one place.
Okay.
In France and is now simultaneously in two places in the U S
wow.
That seems very hard to believe it.
It seems to just violate one of our fundamental notions about how people work.
Metaphysically speaking.
People can't be in two places at the same time.
Yeah,
well maybe that's mythical does that maybe that metaphysical claim I just made
should be abandoned.
Maybe we should say,
oh,
under normal circumstances,
people can't be in two places at the same time.
But if you had something like this,
by Golly,
this guy would be Michigan.
Dude is Napoleon and he's the very same person.
That very same person as New York Dude,
New York Dude and Michigan Dude are a single person.
Napoleon who is by located doesn't happen.
But if it did happen,
it could happen.
Well maybe that's what we should say.
But again,
all I can tell you is I find that too big a price to pay.
People can't.
Okay
be in two places.
It's one thing to say people are spacetime worms extended through space and
extended through time.
It's another thing to say that they are y shaped spacetime worms seems to
violate one of the fundamental metaphysical things about how people work.
All right Ma,
I got to remind you,
none of the options here are all that attractive.
So when I say that,
you don't want to say that.
You don't want to say that we're going to run out of possibilities.
So maybe this is what you'll want to say.
All right.
Saying that Napoleon is in Michigan,
but not New York doesn't seem very attractive.
Say,
and he's in New York,
but not Michigan,
doesn't seem very attractive.
Saying he's in both places at the very same time doesn't seem very attractive.
But what are the possibilities are there if he's not one but not the other,
and if he's not both,
the only other possibility is that he's neither
given this situation.
Neither of these guys is Napoleon.
We've got separate people.
Yeah,
there's the person,
Napoleon spacetime warm that I came to an end in France and there's some,
okay,
spacetime more.
I'm taking place in Michigan,
so I'm a spacetime person where I'm taking place in New York,
but neither of them are Napoleon.
That seems to me to be the least on a tractive of the options we've got
available.
But notice that if we save this,
if we say neither of these guys,
despite having Napoleon's personality,
neither of these guys is Napoleon,
then the personality theory of personal identity is false.
It's rejected.
We're giving up on it because the personality theory,
after all said,
if you got Napoleon's personality,
you're a Napoleon.
But now we've got people that are not in Napoleon,
but they've gotten Napoleon's personality.
So the personality theory follow the personality is wrong if we say neither of
these guys is Napoleon,
but that does seem to be the least unacceptable of the options.
At least that's how it seems to me.
So the personality theories got to be rejected.
Now I think that's right.
I think in fact the personality theory got to be rejected,
but that doesn't mean we couldn't revise it.
We could try to change it in a way that keeps much of the spirit of the
personality theory,
but avoids,
you know,
some of the problems we've just been looking at.
Here's what I think is the best revision available to fans of the personality
theory
they should say.
We were simplifying unduly.
We were simplifying and getting it wrong.
When we said follow the personality,
if you got Napoleon's personality,
that's enough to make you Napoleon.
That's not true.
We need to throw in an extra clause to deal with branching,
splitting cases of this sort that I've just been talking about.
We need to say if there's somebody in the future who's got my personality,
that person is me.
As long as there's only one person around in the future who's got my
personality.
If you have multiple examples,
duplications,
splittings end branchings nobody,
none of them is me.
So where are the original personality theory said?
Same personality.
That's good enough for being the same person.
The new version throws in a no competitors clause throws in a no branching
clause.
It says same personalities good enough.
As long as there's no branching.
If there is branching,
neither of the branches is me.
Now if we say that
if we throw in the no branching clause,
then we're able to say,
look in the original story I was telling you where there was the Michigan guy
who hadn't Napoleon's personality but no New York guy,
that really would be Napoleon.
Okay.
Because it would have the same personality with no competitor.
Similarly had we had somebody with Napoleon's personality in New York and nobody
with the personality in Michigan,
that guy would have been Napoleon cause we would have had the same personality
with no branching with no competitor.
But in the case where we've got branching where we've got somebody with
Napoleon's personality both in Michigan and New York,
that violates the no branching rule and we just have to say nobody's Napoleon in
that case.
And I say that seems to me to be the best revision of the personality theory
available to to them.
So we now need to ask is can we possibly believe that revision?
Can we possibly accept the no branching rule?
The no branching rule seems rather bizarre in its own right.
Thinking about the ordinary familiar cases that we try to,
we're trying to make sense of.
I am the same person as the person that was lecturing to you last time according
to the personality theory or the revised personality theory.
That's because I've got the same personality guy last time thought he was Shelly
Kagan believed he was professor of philosophy.
I think I'm Charlotte Gagan.
I believe I'm the professor of philosophy.
He's got all sorts of memories of his childhood.
I've got the same memories he's got desires about finishing his book.
I've got those desires about finishing my book.
Same personality.
It's me.
That's what the personality theory says.
So I conclude,
hey,
it's me.
I know you were all worried whether I'd survive over the break,
you know,
a couple of days came back.
It's still me.
I made it through Wednesday.
Yeah.
Or did I,
oh,
perhaps I should ask or did he,
yeah,
there was somebody there on Tuesday and yeah,
there's somebody here on Thursday and yeah,
this person here now,
he's got the same personality as the guy who was there on Tuesday.
But according to the no branching rule,
we can't yet conclude that I'm the same person as the person that was lecturing
to you on Tuesday.
We can't conclude that until we know that there aren't any competitors,
but there isn't anybody else right now who also has the same personality.
If I'm the only one around today who's got Shelly Kagan's personality,
that I'm the same person as the person who was lecturing to you on Tuesday.
But if unbeknownst to me,
and I presume unbeknownst to you,
there is somebody in Michigan right now who's got Shelly Kagan's personality,
then we have to say,
Ha,
turns out I'm not Shelly Kagan after all.
Neither is he.
Neither of us are Shelly Kagan.
Shelly Kagan died.
So Am I Shelly Kagan or am I not?
Shelly Kagan can't tell until we know what's going on in Michigan.
Whoa.
That seems very,
very hard to believe whether I am the same person as the person who was
lecturing to you on Tuesday,
presumably should turn on facts about the all that guy who was lecturing to you
on Tuesday and facts about this guy who's lecturing to you today.
On Thursday and maybe some facts about the relationship between that guy and
this guy or that stage and this stage if we prefer to talk about it.
That way we can see how whether it's the same person or not has to turn on the
relations between the stages,
but how could it possibly turn on what's happening in Michigan?
How can whether or not I am the same guy as the guy who was lecturing to you on
Tuesday depend on what's happening in Pennsylvania or Australia or Mars
to you,
some philosophical jargon.
The nature of identity seems like it should depend only on intrinsic facts about
me or perhaps relational facts about the relations between my,
but it shouldn't depend on extrinsic external facts about what's happening
someplace else,
but if we accept the no branching rule were saying whether or not we've got
identity depends on what's happening elsewhere with the no branching rule,
identity ceases to be a strictly internal affair.
It becomes in part and external affair.
That's very,
very hard to believe,
and if you're not prepared to believe it,
it looks as though you've got to give up on the personality view.
Last thought during all of these problems for the personality theorists,
the body theorist,
the fans of the body theorist is standing there laughing.
Ha,
you pour fools.
Look at all the problems you've got.
Adopting the personality theory,
see how easy it is to duplicate personalities leading to these totally
implausible,
no branching rules.
We can avoid all of that if we become body theorists,
but we'll ask ourselves next time is whether or not the body theorist is in a
better situation.